cólera y dengue son algunas de las
enfermedades que empiezan a aparecer en
Pakistán tras las devastadoras
inundaciones que dejó el Monzón según
estimaciones podrían tardar seis meses
en entrenarse el calor en la región es
abrazador con temperaturas de hasta 40
grados Celsius muchos desplazados sin
acceso a agua potable terminan bañándose
y hasta tomando de las aguas estancadas
agravando el problema
hace mucho mucho calor y no tenemos agua
potable pero aquí se ha acumulado mucha
agua de las inundaciones Así que venimos
a beberla y nos bañamos en ella para
refrescarnos
no recibimos agua limpia del gobierno
Así que no tenemos otra opción
excepto beber esta agua que dejó la
inundación
el gobierno dijo este viernes que
intenta contener la epidemia de dengue
no tenemos los datos exactos Pero los
que tenemos más de 4.000 personas están
sufriendo de dengue según los datos que
estamos recibiendo este recuento está
aumentando en unos 150 a 200 pacientes
diarios
está muy extendido pero estamos
intentando contener su vector el
mosquito
los más vulnerables a las enfermedades
son las mujeres y los niños que sufren
de desnutrición en las áreas Rurales
donde además pueden enfrentar problemas
cutáneos como sarna o infecciones
oculares problemas respiratorios agudos
y tifoidea el desastre ocasionado por la
crecida de las aguas ha dejado unos 1500
muertos entre los que hay al menos 528
niños según cifras de las autoridades y
unicef según acnur 16 millones de
menores han sido afectados 3,4 millones
necesitarían ayuda vital inmediata